industry and decision makers in the
nation's capital
[Music]
ronald brownstein
author of the power and the glitter the
hollywood washington connection
why a book
i went out in 1986 when i was still
living in washington working for
national journal covering politics here
and spent some time in los angeles
writing about the early fundraising for
the 1988 presidential campaign
and one of the things i was most struck
by initially was this incredible
confluence of money and politics and
celebrity at every event i mean politics
in washington is sort of a chore often
it's like part of the job in l.a it was
like part of the social life it was like
one of the ways that people who
had money but really didn't have the
social cachet could could mingle and rub
shoulders with the uh the most
celebrated and most famous people in our
country in some ways and uh uh it sort
of crystallized for me at one moment i i
had a dinner uh to meet some of the
younger fundraisers in hollywood we were
sitting around at a friend's house and
talking about politics and i realized
about halfway through this dinner that
everyone at that table had been to ted
kennedy's house except me and i was the
one who lived in washington and i said
that there may be something going on
here and in fact as i began to research
the history i found that there was an
incredibly diverse and rich relationship
that goes back seven decades
how did you approach writing the book
well i started with with the history i
tried to do a great deal of background
reading
on the formation of hollywood on the on
the
what i call the communist detour the the
role of the communist party in hollywood
in the 1930s the blacklist then i began
to look at some less traditional sources
i tried to use archival research quite a
bit to examine the ways that different
presidents related to hollywood and
interacted uh with hollywood i mean
herbert hoover who we do not think of as
sort of a glamour or glitzy guy
in fact was quite close to louis mayer
and william randolph hearst
two of the original powers in hollywood
and in fact mayer was his first
overnight guest in the white house um so
i would i would spend time at the
herbert hoover library in iowa at the uh
at the jfk library in
boston at the lbj library in austin
and then i began to interview people
began to interview
hollywood figures political figures
talked to tom dewey's campaign manager
uh louis mayer's nephew his daughter who
has since died
and
began to try to construct what this
relationship was like in the 1920s and
1930s and 1940s and how it has evolved
over time which i think it has what was
the original draw between
herbert hoover and louis mayer who was
louis mayer louis mayer was the founder
of mgm he was the founding
uh
he was brought in by the low lows
interest to uh to run mgm
became the most powerful man in
hollywood in its first generation he was
the pinnacle through much of the 1930s
he was the most highly paid man in
america
and mayor was someone who understood
power who was very autocratic very
determined to run his studio his way and
yet who also keenly felt sort of the
ostracism of of of hollywood i mean they
simply were not accepted in los angeles
society a very conservative place at the
time they had no social position
and i think they saw politics initially
in the 1920s as a means of establishing
themselves giving themselves legitimacy
and the fact is that louis mayer could
not get his daughter into the best
private schools in los angeles partially
because he was jewish partially because
the studios and hollywood was not seen
as something that respectable people did
but he could get himself into the white
house as the first overnight guest of
the president you can imagine
i think the kind of social force that
that approval had yet in the 1930s and
the social
social lure of politics is reinforced by
very hard-headed business need i mean
the studios are becoming a major
industry hollywood is becoming a major
industry and as such they have more at
stake in their dealings with the
government they learned as many
businesses since have learned that it
pays to have friends in washington
i know you've been on the book tour and
uh you're near the end of it so i got to
ask you the question about all the
people you write about in here who's the
one or two
that you found on the show you've
appeared and are the the everyone's the
most interested in
warren beatty and john f kennedy
in that order in that order i think uh
well that's interesting i'd say it
varies i'd say in that order i think
people are
the people are fascinated by the baby
heart relationship because for this
generation i think like the kennedy
sinatra relationship if we're doing this
25 30 years ago it really is the
emblematic interaction between these two
very different and yet fascinated
communities i mean beatty and heart
the lure between them the the pull that
they felt toward each other the
friendship
really sort of embodies much of what
hollywood and washington have found
interesting about each other for 70
years i mean
warren beatty a very successful actor
director producer nonetheless craved
something more tangible i mean he wanted
a more tangible kind of influence over
the society i mean he felt that he had
something to say he had ideas about
where the society should go and how
campaigns should be run how you sell a
message to the public and he wanted the
the ability to exercise that and gary
hart wanted in addition to political
power uh he he wanted i think that the
glamour and the and the and the the
glitter and the and the excitement that
comes with life among the famous and i
saw so i think i think the people uh
partially because it came to such a sour
end and such a you know really a tragic
end in some ways uh the people are quite
fascinated with that that relationship
kennedy sinatra was somewhat similar in
the in in the kind of attraction
although sinatra did not have the the
ambitions of beatty to be uh politically
influential he just really wanted to be
around
the president i think it was more like
louis mayer he wanted the social
approval he wanted to overcome his past
uh by associating with kennedy but in
fact sinatra was more indelibly stamped
with it than ever because kennedy was
forced to break off the relationship
rather abruptly when evidence
accumulated of alleged ties between
sinatra and the mob
there is a minor mystery in your
acknowledgments
i want to ask you about you say at a
crucial moment mark glitchman and graham
huber stepped in to unravel a technical
tangle that might have held up
completion of the man
what was the indeed oh there was just
just some problem in uh in you know in
in this in this computer era i mean we
you know we're all writing most of us
anyway or i know some of your guests
have talked about writing on legal pads
i've been impressed by that uh we were
writing on computers and i had some
trouble uh switching systems to get out
the draft of the book when i finished it
last year and they helped me make these
computers talk to each other so that i
could get out a clean dress and you know
it's funny because it seemed like it you
know when you're finishing a book i mean
it really feels like you're climbing to
the top of this mountain and at last now
here you are sliding down and i i
remember feeling like great this is all
i need i i've written this book and i
can't get it out of my computer um but
that was that was a crucial moment that
that helped get me on
on to the point where i would actually
have a book to talk about
you also write about your wife yes you
suggest she had a rather large role in
all this well my wife nina easton who i
had written an earlier book with in 1982
when we both lived in washington that
profiled the top 100 people in the
reagan administration
not only had to put up with me as as all
wives or husbands do during the writing
of books but
during the course of my writing this
book she took a job at the los angeles
times
before i did
as a she admitted business week and
took a job covering hollywood
and um she uh began uh you know spending
her time really dealing with the film
community and quite graciously uh
included questions sometimes i would
have interviews remember when she
interviewed betty davis uh toward the
end of her life uh added a few questions
richard gere other people who i either
did not have the time or did not have
the access to because one of the things
that that was most difficult about
writing this book is that moving from
washington to los angeles for a
journalist is
you know is really like a is a dramatic
decline in status in washington
journalists are seen as part of the
process talking to reporters is seen as
part of what you do
in the way that you advance your
political or a policy agenda
in los angeles in general and certainly
in hollywood in particular the press
really isn't seen as having much of a
function i mean to hollywood the press
is a marketing tool it's seen as a way
of promoting movies and the idea that
people will sit down and make themselves
available
for historical inquiry or legitimate
sort of press scrutiny
is is a very alien one there and so
there was quite a bit of fencing and
maneuvering and networking that went
into getting people like warren beatty
and robert redford to sit down uh for
interviews um it was a very uh it was a
very exhaustive process but nina my wife
uh would at
some crucial moments was able to step in
and provide some really
really dramatic assistance in addition
to the usual assistance of uh basically
a living with a person that could be
very difficult to live with when they're
writing a book
did you make anybody mad with this book
oh yeah yeah i think i made a lot of
people mad i mean i think well part of
the um
part of the
an outgrowth of what i was just saying
that hollywood does not have a tradition
really of legitimate press scrutiny is
that people are very sensitive uh
they're not used to being criticized in
any way and i do have some criticisms of
the of the attitude and the approach of
people in hollywood
to politics i mean the basic trend that
i think exists in these 70 years of this
relationship is moving from the louis
mayor vision of of politicians where you
sort of put them up on a pedestal and
you looked up to them as a way of
of establishing your own social
credibility to a growing sense in
hollywood of its own political
legitimacy the sense that they have in
this in this television era where the
lines between entertainment and politics
seem to be blurring that they have every
right to be out there in fact that they
are in some ways more serious about
their politics than the these flighty
money obsessed politicians who are
constantly besieging them for checks and
i think there is a there's an arrogance
and an insularity and elitism that
permeates part of hollywood politics i
think that's quite deen not really
dangerous in the sense of having an
enormous uh impact on the fate of the
republic but
is is demeaning to the politicians and
leads these people sometimes in strange
directions and so i've been critical of
of people like norman lear at times for
this of the hollywood women's political
committee and some of the other powerful
liberal fundraisers for sort of pursuing
what i think is a contradictory vision
of politics i mean sort of an
egalitarian agenda pursued through
elitist means
is hollywood and we're looking at a
picture of george bush and arnold
schwarzenegger is hollywood left or
right
for the last three decades or so
hollywood is clearly lean to the left in
the first decades of the relationship
one of the most interesting things in
researching the book was finding that in
the 30s and 40s and even through the 50s
there was a very strong conservative
contingent in hollywood especially when
you when you consider the country itself
basically a lean democratic in those
years with the predominance of roosevelt
there were people like wendell wilkie
and tom dewey had very enthusiastic
followings in hollywood but by the time
you get to the 1960s
with john f kennedy and then johnson um
there's a sort of realignment in
hollywood um the the younger generation
of the 50s people who rose up through
the 50s in the shadow of the blacklist
which i think is important
basically enlisted in the democratic
party almost entirely and beginning in
the 1960s you see the pattern that
pertains to this day where there are
still conservatives in hollywood but by
and large there are there are smaller
group and they're an older group um
reagan uh just had ronald reagan just
had his 80th uh his 80th birthday party
and you look at the people who were
there i mean it's very familiar faces i
mean jimmy stewart merv griffin uh
and uh there are some younger people tom
selleck but that by and large beginning
in the 60s the younger hollywood has has
moved to the left even the brat packers
coming of age in the in the age of
reagan in the 80s when young people were
very republican uh by and large have
enlisted in democratic politics
first
chapter actually the introduction first
page you say something i want to ask you
about
you say that
creative artist agency president michael
ovitz a talent agent generally
considered hollywood's most powerful man
who is he michael ovitz is the head of a
creative artist agency and uh he is a
person who engineered the deal by which
mca was sold to the japanese
he is someone who was seen as really at
the center of all the different tracks
that run through hollywood one of the
things uh that i discuss in the book is
that the breakdown of the of the studio
system that govern the first decades of
hollywood rearrange not only the the
political life of hollywood with
profound consequences for the things
that i talk about in the book but also
the actual business life of hollywood
and and when the studios mgm 20th
century fox and so forth lost their
dominance of hollywood power shifted to
the agents the first agent who really
understood this was lou wasserman the
the head of mca and really uh
the most powerful political figure in
hollywood of the past 30 years wasserman
understood that in this new era
and the the basic rule of the new era
was the studios no longer held stars on
the binding contract
which is the way the early decades of
hollywood will run agents by brokering
and putting together stars
with projects would have enormous power
wasserman really
understood this he used it he became the
most powerful man in hollywood in his
time of it's a scene as the successor i
just want to jump in and yeah and say
this is lou washington at what age you
know boy this must be at around 40 um in
the uh in the mid in the mid 19 i
believe this in early 1950s it must be
in his 40s if i walked around hollywood
that
looked up and down
i don't even know what the main street
is hollywood and vine and ask everybody
that came by who's the most powerful man
in hollywood but they all say michael
oliver he walked up and down the main
street of any anywhere in l.a no but if
you went to a lunch at the right places
yeah i think they would say michael
ovitz by and large especially because uh
he is a seen as someone who is
very
like wasserman before i'm very conscious
of the exercise of power now all this is
interesting because he represents
something to me which is that you know
in in in terms of the politics of
hollywood and the political role of
hollywood ovitz after being very
apolitical is being drawn gradually into
greater involvement in in politics in
bill bradley's uh
presidential or senate efforts whatever
you know whatever we see out of bill
bradley michael ovitz along with michael
eisner the head of disney will be there
and
what what's sort of been happening over
the last generation is it sort of
institutionalized the idea that if you
are powerful in hollywood whether a star
or an agent or a studio head that you
should have friends in washington you
should be part of the political system i
mean it was it was more of a it was more
of a
not not as a not as direct a need
perhaps seen in the 30s and 40s but
today uh virtually everyone of note in
hollywood uh feels the need to get
involved in politics like robert de niro
has no causes it's sort of an oddity
uh michael ovitz what
what's he like and where's he come from
and does he have real power when it
comes to things outside of hollywood in
the political world well i don't think
ovitz has a lot i don't think all this
has a lot of political influence yet
outside of the outside of the uh
hollywood community itself where his
influence is tremendous over to sort of
a veiled and very um
secretive maybe too strong a word uh guy
but someone who keeps himself like lou
wasserman before him again following the
model established i think by wasserman
tries to keep himself out of the press
keep a very low profile and yet exercise
tremendous power
behind the scenes i think that as he
continues to be drawn into the political
world uh we'll continue to uh to follow
in that way you think about wasserman
for a moment wasserman has been close to
democratic presidents for three decades
johnson and carter in particular and yet
he is someone
who has been extraordinarily averse to
publicity he is a i described in the
book he was seen by the people around uh
presidents as the rare guy who did not
want his photo taken with the president
he'd rather just know that he could pick
up the phone if the occasion ever arose
page 183 in 1952 the company
aggressively lobbied for and won a
blanket waiver from the screen actors
guild freeing
it from the union's prohibition against
agents acting simultaneously as
producers the waiver was arguably the
most important event in mca history
beginning its metamorphosis from a
talent agency to a studio the agreement
also marked a turning point in the
fortunes of mca client ronald reagan yes
absolutely this has been an event that
was not only in some ways the pivotal
event in the history of mca which has
been
a crucial player perhaps in some ways
the most important player in hollywood
over the last several decades but
something that's caused controversy
uh for for decades i mean ronald reagan
mca client
fading uh fading career at this point uh
mca wins a blanket waiver from sag
screen actors guild prohibition on
agents simultaneously acting as
producers goes on to become a dominant
force in network television production
in the 50s and and begins the the
evolution from a talent agency into a
studio uh which it completed in the
1960s at some under duress from the
kennedy justice department to some
extent reagan's career then revised
revives and people forever
have alleged that there was a deal the
justice department investigated
reagan uh testified uh in a rather
blurry manner as can be his style on
occasion uh to the events of the earlier
time uh and uh there has forever been
this debate uh the defenders of the deal
point out that mca
did agree for the first time to give
actors residual payments for the
repeated showing of television uh
programming and that whatever the
relationship with reagan that something
very important was given to the to the
film community in the deal i mean one
agent said to me you know uh all of
these are writers and directors and
actors should be down kissing reagan's
feet because half the homes in the san
fernando valley were built on the
residuals that they won in that deal but
it has that deal i think has been
enshrined in hollywood lore and sort of
one of the things that is often cited by
the left in hollywood is why they never
trusted reagan i mean there's sort of
this long-standing antipathy to reagan
on the hollywood left william weiler i
quote a quote someone in the book who
was told by william weiler the great
director in the 1960s after reagan was
elected governor
we'd only given ronnie a few more good
parts maybe none of this would have
happened so uh there
there there's always been an antipathy
for reagan
this is one of the moments at which it
began
lou wasserman a democrat heavily
involved in the johnson administration
and fundraising and
what is he 74 75 years old yeah 76
probably
often credited during the reagan years
as being one of those that helped ronald
reagan like you're saying here uh were
they close well they it's very
interesting i think one of the most
interesting things to me in doing the
research was they were close uh when
wasserman was his agent but their
relationship had clearly frayed by the
time that reagan
arrived in the white house i mean i
think that wasserman um
preoccupied with the duties of building
a studio had less time for reagan in the
50s when reagan's career was sort of on
the
on the ropes and reagan i think felt uh
somewhat hurt by this and wasserman in
turn i was told was hurt when reagan
bickered over taking his last role in
the killers in 1964 because he felt that
reagan should be grateful and take the
role and i think reagan
was worried about playing an
unsympathetic character right before
going into a political career um so
there was this sort of frayed
relationship which i think very few
people in hollywood were aware of but
wasserman with the sort of skill and
subtlety that really is is his his
trademark rebuilt the relationship when
reagan was in the white house he i was
told that he provided some subtle
assistance in the 1980 campaign even
while
essentially helping jimmy carter 1984
spoke more favorably about reagan
perhaps opened some doors and then got
very heavily involved in the fundraising
for the reagan library to the point
where when ronald reagan left the white
house and returned to los angeles the
first man he had lunch with was lou
wasserman
you uh
you paint a picture of lou washington on
one of your pages in here of a man who
uh had a rather interesting temper uh is
that new information or is that
something that is well known in
hollywood well i think it's reasonable
you know i think i think it's reasonably
well known in hollywood and not
discussed um there are as i said before
i mean hollywood is not a place used to
publicly discussing the way things
really run and wasserman is an
interesting figure because i mean if
you've ever seen him in public on the
rare times we do see him in public he is
so icily self-controlled i mean he's a
man in just perfect control very
soft-spoken very quiet but in private he
can get quite enraged and he's a temper
that was quite fearsome he's a real task
master he was a real driven man i mean
if you look at wasserman in the 50s and
60s as i say in the book he really is
the only
one of the successor generation of to
the moguls who display their same kind
of brute ambition i mean this is sort of
this ferocious desire to build an empire
uh with all of that entails and that is
what really led him into the political
arena because he found as a mayor and
zanec before him that his interests
could be affected not only by the people
in hollywood that he had basically cowed
but also by the government and in 1962
when the justice department
begins and forces the the final severing
of the talent agency of mca from their
studio operation
the feeling as has been enshrined in mca
lore the company lure that was the
moment really at which wasserman
understood that the low political
profile that mca had been famous for in
its early decades really couldn't apply
anymore they needed to have juice they
needed to have friends
and they went out and rather
dramatically acquired them
his temper was legendary stories
percolated through the company of men
who fainted under tongue lashing from
wasserman
or who were rushed from his office dazed
and humiliated and promptly threw up
absolutely wasserman enraged was
fearsome to watch his voice would rise
and in his agitation he would begin to
lisp and slur his words
is that a normal kind of activity on the
part of a hollywood mogul well it it's a
little excessive even for the hollywood
moguls of today i think louis mayer you
know louis mayer was so fierce at times
that dory sherry who was who succeeded
him as the head of mgm was quite close
to adley stevenson and became an
important political figure in his own
right wrote in his memoirs of being in
louis mayor's office while louis mayer
berated someone else so ferociously that
sherry left the room and threw up so
there is a history of perhaps wretching
in the executive suites of hollywood but
wasserman is a figure of such personal
power
in the film community
that
you know he can get away with an awful
lot i talk about in the book he could be
very hard on politicians also i mean he
could he could press his case with a
vigor and intensity and that is very
rare because he had these relationships
he had this self-confidence i tell a
story of uh of a fundraiser for dick
gephardt trying to interest him in the
1988 presidential campaign at a time
when uh dick gephardt was
supporting the directors in their
efforts to stop the colorizing of old
films uh and this was very much opposed
by the studios and wasserman sort of
howls into the phone
what does dick gephardt care about the
colorizing of movies telling he doesn't
like color movies to go around and take
the goddamn color knobs off every
television you know and that kind of
thing i mean it's very hard you know the
kind of very assertive behavior that
very few people could get away with
ronald brownstein
of what
native city new york city
new york to washington to los angeles
sort of a trifecta here on
centers of disparate american
communities what was family life like in
new york city for you grew up in queens
father was an electrician
attended public schools
and went to state university public
university in new york
studied what studied english literature
and history
but worked on always was involved in
journalism's editor my college paper
editor of my high school paper
came down to washington
after graduating worked with ralph nader
for a few years
then worked at national journal here in
washington uh covering the white house
and national politics before moving to
l.a to
to write this book and
get a little air
what did you do for ralph nader i wrote
um we
when i came out of school
in 79 there were um sort of like a plane
stacked up over o'hare there were all of
these manuscripts and books and reports
that had been either half finished or
three-quarter finished
and i recruited hired a group of writers
and edited and basically put out a
number of these uh these books and
reports and then wrote a couple of my
own
put out a book on the environment
co-authored and then in 1982 i wrote a
book with nina easton my wife called
reagan's ruling class that profiled the
top hundred people in the reagan
administration uh in in considerable
depth involved interviewing about 60 of
them and several hundred other people um
and i went to work at national journal
are you a believer in ralph nader
uh i you know i think i think nader uh
is has been certainly one of the most
remarkable forces in
in in washington um and in america i
mean i i was talking to someone the
other day about so when you think about
the
some of the subtle impacts that nader
has had just the sheer idea
of
influencing debate in washington without
any institutional base i mean i think
that i think he really cemented that
idea uh i think that i mean he's gone
through his up periods and his down
periods but he's persevered and he has
an idea which is something that very few
people in washington uh you know really
have and he has a vision of what he's
about you know would ralph nader ever
get caught up with the hollywood types
well it's funny when there was an
excerpt of the book in vanity fair of
about the baby heart relationship and
they had this photo of of ralph uh and
warren beatty together uh in sort of
matching sunglasses i think it was my
favorite photo in this whole sort of
wall of photos that they had collected
about the baby with every politician
under the sun
i think nader like anyone else i mean
really it's striking that anyone
involved in advancing political causes
particularly without as i said before a
large institutional base inevitably
finds themselves in hollywood i mean
yeah nader has been out there he's
raised some money he's he's worked with
celebrities to publicize his causes uh
you look at virtually any cause that
that basically has to attract attention
and that really is the anti in the in
the modern political era essentially to
attract the attention of tv uh is the
way that you begin to shape public
debate in this society and that as i
talk about in the book i mean that
inevitably leads you to hollywood
because these uh celebrities are magnets
for the camera and also the there are
people there there's an unusually large
concentration of people in this
community who are willing to fund
politics around ideology not parochial
business interest i mean there's there's
a large contingent of that i mean
there's the wasserman wing of hollywood
which which has which has an ideology
but essentially is primarily involved in
protecting their business interests
that's not very unusual that's anywhere
troy you know atlanta what what is
unusual is that you have this other
group of very affluent people who are
willing to put money into ideological
causes such as those that ralph nader
pursues and such as those that you know
insurgent candidacies george mcgovern
raised a lot of money in hollywood
you can find support for
um
crusades that are not at the center the
comfortable center of the american
political spectrum in hollywood
anything about the hollywood washington
connection that really bothers you as
far as the future is concerned yeah
absolutely i mean i think the main i
don't think that hollywood itself
trivializes american politics and i
don't think that that arnold
schwarzenegger or charlton heston or
richard gere or richard dreyfuss are
powerful enough to
demean our politics as some people have
suggested i think though the very the
fact that the trend that we're looking
at here of of
a blurring of the lines between
entertainment and politics of the sense
in hollywood that these people that we
belong in this debate reflects a broader
problem which is the the marginalization
of politics and american life i mean the
fact is that causes i don't think are
being irrational when they say that we
have to bribe the public to pay
attention by occasionally putting a
famous face atop one of these debates
but the fact that they are in that
position uh does trouble me the other
thing that troubles me is the is the uh
it reflects again a broader problem
the focus on fundraising the obsession
with raising money that afflicts these
politicians which puts them uh in not
only in the very demeaning position of
coming on bended knee to studio moguls
or producers but also forces them to
spend a disproportionate of their time
disproportionate amount of their time
hanging around rich people i mean as i
said before i mean one of the things
that's most troubling about the
hollywood political scene is this almost
unconscious but incredibly pervasive
elitism i mean there is a there's a
notion that the people who want to be
president should have to pass through
our living room and pass our muster and
i find that quite offensive and you can
look at this as one of you can probably
see this in other communities but to
some extent it's more purified here that
when people politicians come to la
they don't spend time
by and large in east l.a they don't
spend time with the new immigrant
communities they're forced to spend an
awful lot of time beseeching these
people in bel air and brentwood living
these very comfortable lives to open
their checkbooks and i think that is a
troubling trend also which politicians
are besides the gary hart's the past
story which politicians of today are the
most tied to hollywood
well i think that there are a number of
democrats who will have quite a bit of
support in hollywood should they choose
to run for president bill bradley uh
clearly has a strong financial base in
hollywood i start the book as you
mentioned before with the story of bill
bradley raising 600 thousand dollars on
a single night in los angeles not all of
that from hollywood but much of it from
hollywood and also from these
surrounding liberal communities that
interact with it bob kerry i think will
do very well uh in hollywood should he
choose to run for president could expect
a lot of support not only because of his
relationship with deborah winger which
gives him an end to the film community
but also because he fits the model of
what hollywood likes in a politician i
mean you look at the kind of politicians
who appealed to hollywood by and large
gary hart john f kennedy adley stevenson
there's as much style there as there is
a there's a glamour there's a you know
there's more than just
a substance and i think hollywood does
like to be charmed they like to be wowed
and i think kerry uh has a little bit of
that chris dodd has done well out there
john kerry uh has done well out there
joe kennedy for obvious reasons um has a
lot of friends in hollywood and raises
money uh just about anybody who sits on
the relevant committees can have a
luncheon at one of the studios and and
do very well too any republican well
yeah i mean i think like warren hatch
for example and alan simpson very
unlikely
but have raised money because they've
had a say on some of the issues that
concern the studios george bush has a
share of support in hollywood also i
think you know schwarzenegger uh arnold
schwarzenegger is an interesting figure
because he's someone who clearly enjoys
this and is likely to play a larger and
larger role in conservative politics in
the 90s in the 80s just about every
cause uh conservative cause
tapped on charlton heston i mean heston
was was there for everything he was
there defending reagan he was there for
the nra he was there on el salvador he
was the sort of conservative poster boy
in hollywood in the 80s i suspect that
in the 90s he is going to be supplanted
by schwarzenegger not only because he's
a bigger star but also because he has a
lot of enthusiasm for this and i think
he enjoys being out there and enjoys
being part of the process who in
hollywood will you expect to run for
office and possibly be successful and do
you see any hollywood figure ever doing
what ronald reagan did in the near
future
i have trouble envisioning that i mean i
think i'm spending a lot of time with
these people i talk to people like
beatty and redford at length and they
are often mentioned robert redford as a
potential candidate warren beatty in
1976
even publicly mused about running for
president as a stand-in for humphrey or
kennedy against against carter but i
think inevitably they're drawn back away
from the starting gate because the life
of the actor is very different from the
life of the politician despite what the
surface similarities that some have
recorded i mean the fact is that you
have enormous control
as an actor over the kind of exposure
you have to the public and the press and
you can always get behind the gate and
close the door you can decide to answer
what you want to answer and when you
don't like the question you can say next
question
politicians have to put up with an awful
lot that robert redford or warren beatty
or james garner who was talked about as
running for governor
in california last year i think that the
people who actually cross over the
changelings like reagan and george
murphy will remain very much the
exceptions on the other hand i do
believe that in this in this sort of era
of
of politics where the key is the ability
of how well how well you can present
yourself on tv your ability to project
truthfulness to project sincerity on tv
there will be a continuing draw to that
because i think politicians i know a lot
of i can think of a number of stars who
sort of look at the politicians and say
i could do that and i can do that better
when did you finish writing what was the
last date that you put words on paper uh
it would have been last january oh well
last january i turned in the
the finnish manuscript and then i
revised it again through may and june uh
i would say sometime in june uh with uh
some reconsideration of the role of
helen gahagan douglas in the 1940s and
how that influenced hollywood i was uh i
was uh finished
and uh how is it done you mentioned
vanity vanity fair we had a yeah we had
extensive excerpts it's been excerpted
in vanity fair the new york times sunday
arsenal leisure l.a times lears and
mother jones magazine and we've had i
think pretty good reviews i mean we've
been reviewing the washington post in
the new york times l.a times in boston
globe time magazine
and uh we're out there you know just
trying to uh you know find a trying to
find an audience how will it affect you
think your own career
i don't know the answer i mean i think
um uh when i wrote the last i seem to uh
i seem to switch
uh my take my career uh junctures at the
completion of books when i finished
reagan's ruling class i left ralph nader
and went to work for national journal uh
when i finished this i i left national
journal where i had still been
associated as west coast correspondent
and went to work at the la times as a
national political correspondent i mean
i'd like to continue uh alternating
between journalism and uh and books
got three pictures i want to ask you
about and they're they're
some old-timers yeah helen and
melvin douglas
who are they
melvin douglas a star of light screen
comedy at mgm in the 1930s and 40s and
perhaps the key democrat in hollywood of
that era
helen gahegan douglas his remarkable
wife
who was an actress herself she starred
in she the original version of she's a
cult classic and was also a singer of
great renown who became drawn to
politics
even more than her husband at first her
husband was the one who had the contacts
in the white house and in the new deal
and was and was the one who campaigned
around the state but beginning in 1938
with the formation of something called
the steinbeck committee which john
steinbeck had had founded to help the
the the uh okies that he wrote about in
in the grapes of wrath living this you
know this terrible life in california at
the time she was sort of drawn in by the
misery and and became very active in
that became active speaking around the
state and found herself increasingly
drawn to the political world to the
point where in 1944 with the
encouragement of franklin roosevelt who
saw her as a counterweight for the
democrats to claire booth loose who had
been elected to congress as a republican
two years earlier she ran for congress
and won and served three terms uh before
going down and defeat in 1950 in a
remarkable and legendary senate race to
richard nixon why was it legendary well
it was it was really a ferocious uh
contest and one in which nixon
you know acquired the label of tricky
dick uh it was one in which helena hagen
douglas was mercilessly a red-baited
first by her democratic opponent a
newspaper publisher in los angeles
during the primary and then by nixon i
mean this is the period in which uh an
extremely important period in
hollywood's political development in
which the the idea of alliance between
liberals and communists which was very
prevalent in the 1930s really dominated
hollywood's political participation the
popular front of of liberals and
communists against fascism had collapsed
with the cold war and then the
conservatives at the house on american
activities committee came in and began
to pick through the debris really of
what was already falling apart and and
begin the persecution of communists in
hollywood and helen gahagan douglas
merely by association with the hollywood
of the of the depression era the
hollywood of the pre-war era was was
subject to attack uh for allegedly
associating with communists in fact both
her and her husband were among the most
skeptical in hollywood from the
beginning of alliance with communists
and melvin douglas sometimes found
himself under attack on both sides he
was accused of being a communist and
then he was attacked by the communists
their marriage last and how long do they
live
their marriage did last although uh um i
think melvin
the sense that i had from the interviews
that i conducted was that he never fully
adjusted to her succeeding him
as the as the dominant political voice
he was invisible in her campaigns and he
played very little role and also receded
from politics entirely once she emerged
it was clear that it was very difficult
for him to sort of walk into a room i
think and have her be the person that
people were looking for in politics uh
their marriage endured and they lived
they lived a long life into the i
believe she died in the
late 70s or early 80s
orson welles orson welles um who are
these people orson welles the people
surrounded around him in the picture are
the are the reporters interviewing him
on the occasion of his war of the worlds
broadcast in 1938 where he uh where he
shocked the nation i mean orson walls is
really a an incredible figure as i say
in the book there seemed to be more
hours in his day i mean he was he was on
radio he was he was he was on a hit in
the theater he was coming out to
hollywood to make citizen kane and yet
he found time to be involved in a whole
panoply of liberal causes writing for a
magazine called the free world which was
involved in international affairs
campaigning feverishly for roosevelt in
1944 sophie virtually that he literally
collapsed with 104 fever
10 days before the election wells was
someone who
i think envisioned at this point in his
life that he could do anything i mean i
think he could have imagined himself
being a senator he thought about running
for senate in 1946 out of california who
could have envisioned himself being a
national candidate someday at some point
there was a rally in 1944 where um henry
wallace after he had been dumped from
the ticket for harry truman uh spoke at
madison square garden with with orson
welles and a number of other hollywood
celebrities hollywood was very involved
in that roosevelt campaign but on the
way out of the of the rally uh wells is
mobbed by fans who rock his car and
chant wallace and wells in 48. and
oyster wilds would have thought that's
quite reasonable
what was the war of the worlds broadcast
oh he when he when he uh when he did his
uh 1938 halloween night uh he did a um
a mock invasion of mars a mock invasion
from mars which became legendary because
it generated panic all up and down the
east coast where he broadcast uh he
broadcast the war of the worlds as if it
was really occurring with news broadcast
cutting in and so forth and it proved to
be you know a sensation that really for
the first time made him a national
figure i mean he was a he was a
theatrical hit in new york uh but this
sort of incredibly audacious stunt which
which was much in character for him at
that point in his life he had not sort
of yet been beset by entropy and sort of
scattered energy
this was something that first brought
him to the public's attention did he do
that for political reasons no no that
was that was that was
sort of the great showman
at that point
but wells had that sort of showman skill
when he came to politics he was a very
um
uh ornate uh speaker uh he was uh he was
very dramatic uh he would stand in
occasionally in the 44 campaign he would
appear for roosevelt he appeared at one
forum opposite thomas dewey the opponent
and he was someone who really had a
great gift for this sort of thing he
even wrote a column after the 44
campaign he wrote a political column a
five day a week political column
envisioning himself moving more deeply
into this world but it never really
happened his life begins to sort of fall
apart in the second half of the 40s and
he ends up leaving the country
the gentleman on the left linda wilkie
on the right daryl zanik what's the
reason for this picture
daryl zaneck of the first generation of
moguls was in some ways the most
brilliant filmmaker i mean he was he was
respected the most by people like orson
welles as someone who had some who was
really a brilliant filmmaker in his own
right and he thought he believed like
warren beatty a generation later he
really is the the antecedent to warren
beatty he believed the insights that he
had of the public through making films
fully equipped him to plot the strategy
of a modern presidential campaign and he
and he was very much involved in both
1940 the wilkie campaign and in the 44
wilkie attempt to get the nomination and
also in the 52 eisenhower campaign in
peppering the senior campaign staff with
memos strategy suggestions ideas
he was so close to wilkie that he
engineered wilkie's appointment as
chairman of the board of 20th century
fox uh and was someone who saw in
himself really the prototype of the
modern political strategist i mean he
would send memos to nixon in 1952 that
talking about quite truly i think how
television had changed the rules of
campaigning and how politicians had to
begin to understand that
let's uh pretend for a moment that
you're going to be a candidate for
congress the senate or even the
presidency who's the first person you
would call in hollywood for money and
support well historically it would be
lou wasserman as a democrat even today
you do that today i think i think you
would start with that as a as a mark of
respect i mean there is that sort of
danish
aspect to hollywood where you where you
demonstrate respect
but i think that in a practical sense
you would look you look for someone
especially the congressman of the
senators you're not really going to get
lou wasserman i think or or some of the
other studio chiefs to put out a lot of
effort for you unless it's a very
particular reason bob graham from
florida does very well at disney for
obvious reasons people support him i
think what you look for you look for an
angel i mean you look for someone who is
trying to make their name even as you
are making yours because much as uh
politicians
how well they do depends on the quality
of the sponsor they find in hollywood
people in hollywood
achieve a certain status based on the
quality of the people they sponsor uh
and so you find people who are on the
way up i mean look at bill bradley is a
good example i mean in the dawn of his
political career he makes friends with
michael eisner who then is a young
executive at paramount michael eisner
goes on to bigger and better things as
the head of disney and arguably the most
powerful studio person in hollywood and
michael eisen raises money for bill
bradley over the years and he introduces
him to his friend michael ovitz uh and
together uh michael ovitz and michael
eisner introduce bill bradley to their
friends which is about anybody who
matters in hollywood and and you and you
have this sort of network that expands i
think
hollywood has become somewhat jaded i
mean they're so beseeched by politicians
it's very hard to start at the top you
have to find someone in the middle level
uh who will who will rise with you let's
go back again though let's say you don't
know lou wasserman you don't know
michael ovitz and michael eisner who
else could you call yeah you know you
just you say there's some money out
there for me and i need to get into that
community this is this is really i mean
this has become an absolute profession
at this point there are you know in
washington this would be an unusual verb
but in hollywood there are people who do
politics that's what they do they do
politics
stars and producers alike now have
people on their staffs who do politics
norman lear has an aide who does his
politics richard dreyfuss has an aide
who does his politics michael ovitz has
an aide who does his politics ted field
uh has has a has an aide and advisor who
does this politics who's ted field ted
field is a producer multi-millionaire
heir to the field fortune um marshall
marshall field fortune and uh uh
certainly among the wealthiest men in
hollywood and and basically what you do
then as a candidate is you call these
people that's okay do you know any of
the names of the doers of politics sure
name one
uh bob roquette uh who works for works
for ted field uh used to work for norman
lear and is very heavily involved in
democratic fundraising
if someone is someone who whose phone
does ring uh with democratic candidates
all the time i mean i think he once told
me a story about having a uh having a
lawn sale at his house you know a garage
sale to get rid of some stuff and he
started pawing through all these curios
from his garage
and there is like representative tom
daschle who wants to be senator tom
daschle uh and that's the kind of thing
that happens in hollywood i mean people
in hollywood as i said have become so
barraged by the pursuit of by the
politicians pursuing money that they
become somewhat jaded and they expect an
awful lot of stroking and courting and
and the rule of thumb in the political
community i think in washington is that
you have to go out and make several
trips you have to spend time getting to
know you i talked to cindy pollock the
director who you know he says you know
you you you do a little something you
hold a fundraiser at your house and all
of a sudden the call starts sydney i'm
going to be out in los angeles uh maybe
we could have lunch sort of like they're
just dropping by as if they were on the
way to the beach and so you know
senators and congressmen are always
passing through always trolling around
always looking for a new angel someone
who can unlock these golden doors and
produce some cash
bob burkett is that what was his noble
cat
uh you call bob on the phone and yes
you tell him your situation what's the
first thing he's going to do how does he
shake you if he doesn't want to deal
with you or how does he immediately help
you if he wants to i think if bob
doesn't want to deal with you he just
doesn't take the call eventually he will
i think i think but he's going to take
your if you're a congressman if you're a
congressman eventually what they do is
um
they will they will meet they will meet
with these people and depending upon how
much they want to help them they will
either talk about how overwhelmed they
are and how barraged they are uh or they
will um arrange a small fundraiser
and a gradually arranged a larger
fundraiser i mean these people by the
way it's a two-way process i mean i
think the people like bob roquetto is
very shrewd about his politics
they go out and seek rising politicians
as well i mean they went out and
likewise eisner and ovitz
went out and built some links to bill
bradley did some fundraising for him
because they want to be connected as
well they want to be part of the process
of shaping the leadership in this case
of the democratic party
one of the fundraisers a guy named david
stein who was a very important
fundraiser for gary hart in
1984 real estate developer in orange
county very tied into the hollywood
political scene i thought really
encapsulated it well in one quote we
were talking once and said you know if
uh if you got a congressman who has a
tough race he'll call you up and say
david the republicans have targeted me
i've got this tough race can you raise
me ten thousand dollars
somebody wants to be president somebody
wants a presence and they'll call you up
and say david you want to go camping i
mean there is the there is the you know
there's this building of relationship
that goes on there and there's a sort of
uh this this bizarre courting ritual i
mean it's sort of strange to think of
people who want to be president spending
time
courting
uh the people who who make this sort of
you know celluloid to spend their time
constructing celluloid fantasies but the
fact is that it is
an accepted and almost inevitable stop
on the path to the white house has it
paid off for hollywood
for hollywood yeah why the industry well
i think well there are two separate
there are really two separate ways to
measure that um as an industry
protecting narrow industry interest
hollywood is very good in hollywood in
their perennial battles with the
networks over the control of syndicated
programming does very well hollywood
puts a lot of money into politics
studios now i'm talking about
institutional hollywood puts a lot of
money into politics and yes defends its
interest quite effectively jack valenti
is widely regarded as one of the most
effective lobbyists in washington now on
the other hand the other side of
hollywood the ideological side of
hollywood i think is often disappointed
i mean i think they feel these
politicians never really carry through
aren't really serious aren't willing to
go to the last uh you know the last inch
of ground and fighting on el salvador or
nicaragua or abortion i mean hollywood
tends to be in its political expression
on both left and right rather militant
rather extreme is rather purist
for reasons that i talk about in the
book and i think that as a result
they are constantly disappointed by the
politicians the hollywood women's
political committee for example which is
a very powerful organization raises a
lot of money for democrats i mean often
treats the politicians who come out
there as as people have strayed from the
true path i mean they sort of view them
as not quite as committed as they are in
some ways maybe they're not you mention
in your acknowledgments that you've
interviewed 325 people for this book
who wouldn't talk to you
and our
same question is who was your biggest
disappointment that wouldn't talk
biggest disappointment was harry
belafonte
because i believe that he really played
a crucial role in the evolution of how
people in hollywood viewed fame and
viewed the eye and how the idea took
root that fame could be a kind of
political tool that's really what i
track in the book it's almost in some
ways a social history of fame and and
the way that fame and and celebrity has
become seen as a form of social power in
the society because of the platform that
it gives you belafonte as a as a black
actor black star had something that very
few blacks in america had in the 1950s
and 1960s he had a platform to address
white america and i think although he
felt he felt somewhat almost uh he felt
resentful almost that he had to shoulder
this responsibility he really did
shoulder it and he used the platform
with extraordinarily extraordinarily
effectively very heavily involved in the
civil rights movement and i would have
liked to talk to him
stars can be very difficult to get to as
i said before i mean the stars tend to
view the press primarily as a means of
promoting what they do and it can be
very hard to cut through all the layers
and get to them it took enormous
persistence to get to the people that i
did like betty like redford john
houseman a number of from all different
eras um the other disappointment was
sinatra
wouldn't talk to me why well i think
because at this point sinatra doesn't
want to be doesn't want to have to
justify his life to anybody and
even though
i think
that the treatment of him in there is is
rounded i don't think it's one-sided i
mean there's a whole chapter in the book
about the kennedy's natural relationship
um i i don't think he wanted to go
through it answer all the old questions
again
what was your favorite one or two
interviews where you walked out of there
with that
stenographer's notebook and said i you
know this is it uh well i think probably
my single favorite interview was the
beatty interview because it was so
difficult to finally get warren beatty
to sit down i mean it was like
corralling smoke as i say i mean it just
took months and months of conversation
back and forth but when we finally did
sit down
we talked at great length we talked for
a day and a half
and beatty is really a fascinating
figure i mean he's very elliptical he
can be very vague he can be very
difficult to pin down but his insights
can be quite surprising as well and i
enjoy the the sparring that was going on
this was at that point before dick tracy
and he had not done a one-on-one
interview in five years
uh and um it was it was uh that was i
think that was a very uh very worthwhile
i also enjoyed very much talking to some
of the older writers some of the people
who had been in hollywood in the 1930s
and 1940s about what life was like in
the studios and how politics really
first came to hollywood in in the talent
of the depression with the rise of the
fascists really being the key uh in
europe and and how the communist party
took root and what it was like uh in the
sort of very uneasy alliances between
liberals and communists in the 30s and
40s i really enjoyed uh sort of that
that history as well you mentioned it
took you a year and a half to talk
through uh an appointment with more
invaders about a year about a year or
whatever
you i mean you you'd talk to him
directly and say i want to do this and
you he'd say no
no no he wouldn't say no first of all in
hollywood people people only refuse you
by saying yes and that's one of the
things about hollywood no one ever says
no they just say yes till you go away
they just keep saying yes yes yes but
nothing ever happens baby's a little
different i mean
say in the book gary hart called him the
phantom i mean beatty is a very elusive
character it's just sort of hard to
figure out where he is he's sort of the
disembodied voice over the telephone and
what would happen would be that we
would set up we would we would sort of
agree he had agreed to do the interview
and he would say call me in a week and
we'll set it up and i call him in a week
and it's like call me monday and i call
him monday and say call me tuesday and
call on friday and it was like we'd at
one point we were virtually talking
every day on the phone but without
getting any closer or further away from
actually having this interview and when
we finally set it up it was during the
latter stages of dick tracy um finally
set it up finally got it you know i sort
of pestering him making a pest of myself
and finally he agreed to meet me at his
office at four o'clock get there about
quarter four and i'm sitting there in
the office and waiting for warren beatty
which is rather
an office is really two grand a term i
mean it's like basically this empty room
with a desk and a couch and at 10 to
four madonna walks in
and at this point i realize that i am in
trouble because this is often the case
warren baby is double booked
and if it came down to me or madonna you
can imagine which one is going to stay
and which one is going to be told to
return in fact after a few
minutes of
sort of sitting across the room looking
at each other with her really unsure
what i was or what i was doing there uh
beatty arrived and very apologetically
asked me to come back
and you came back i came back about
finally i came back about a couple hours
later and we spent two hours that night
went over to his house
and spent almost the entire next day
together
and he really talked at great length he
likes talking off the record as well as
on the record and had quite a lot to say
almost out of time got another book
you ready to write
not quite yet i'm looking forward to
covering the 92 presidential campaign
for the la times and i think about
something after that but not until then
got any uh predictions on who you think
would be the democratic standard bearer
boy they're going to have to get
somebody to run i mean
it's like it's very hard to say i mean
because you can't even measure the field
because there is no field what is
hollywood and i don't know you can use a
word hollywood all-encompassing think
will be the candidate and who will they
support i don't know who they think but
i think that bob carey would be the one
they'd most like to see out there on the
democratic side bill bradley
i think bradley would do very well too
but i think kerry inspires a little more
excitement among the non-financial
people among the stars i think kerry
would do better in the long run
our guest is the author of this book
called the power and the glitter
all about the hollywood washington
connection ronald brownstein thank you
very much for being with us thanks for
having me
[Music]
that concludes this edition of book
notes and our conversation with ronald
brownstein author of the power and the
glitter the hollywood washington
connection
for a printed transcript of this week's
edition of book notes and five dollars
to tape writer incorporated box 885
lincolnshire illinois 60069
up next it's question time from
britain's house of commons
[Music]
hello